amélioration du climat d'investissement
dans l'extrême orient russe a été un des
sujets principaux de ce forum économique
orientale j'ai décidé de faire le tour
de l'exposition pour voir justement où
l'on peut investir dans sept régions
russes
là
bienvenue dans la région de
transbaïkalie est une terre extrêmement
riche en ressources naturelles vous y
trouvez du fer du charbon de l'or de
cuivre d'ailleurs son gisement de cuivre
est le plus grand en russie mais pas mal
aussi d'opportunités d'investir dans les
secteurs d'agriculture
[Musique]
bienvenue au kamtchatka une des régions
les plus pittoresques russe pas mal de
possibilités d'investir ici les projets
d'infrastructures à la star sociaux mais
aussi les projets touristiques
il paraît que les cours de certaines
sont les néo monde est
[Musique]
bienvenu dans la région du magasin le
leader russe en extraction de l'or et de
l'argent l'année dernière par exemple
ils ont extrait presque 50 tonnes d'or
et 572 tonnes d'argent nous on va aussi
essayer de trouver en dehors il 6e le
stand
bon j'imagine les spectateurs d'air
france ont déjà à laver lors plusieurs
fois dans leur vie donc ne critiquez pas
trop ma technique je vais essayer de
trouver un petit lingot d'or ici
et voilà
les chants chamanique sont extrêmement
puissants c'est bien connu il ne serait
pas étonnant qu'ils attirent les
investissements
[Musique]
nous